turning now to a state that's becoming a
go-to destination for movie and
television Productions I was thinking I
think the copy is wrong we already
talked about this this is a different
story we're talking about Oklahoma where
multiple Productions have been filmed
including Sylvester Stallone's Tulsa
King have you seen this yet Matt Damon
Stillwater and Leonardo DiCaprio's
killers of the flower move
flower Moon sorry thank you Tony flower
Moon Omar villafranco shows us why this
date is being called Hollywood on the
Prairie
okay
with all the lights
cameras roll camera and action this
looks like a movie set in Hollywood but
it's 1300 miles away and one of the
fastest growing places to shoot a movie
Oklahoma TJ you ready yes sir okay my
friend set DJ Zachary recently graduated
from film school at Oklahoma City
Community College a program that's
working not to send graduates to
Hollywood I want to be near my family I
want to make movies with people that I
enjoy and if I left the state I wouldn't
be able to do that as much
but to get them ready for when Hollywood
comes to shoot movies and TV shows here
in Oklahoma it takes a cast of film
veterans training a small army of crew
members so Hollywood can hire locally
and add an advantage
one reason Tinseltown is drawn to the
middle of the country is money Oklahoma
lawmakers are luring Production Studios
and creating local jobs with a 30
million rebate program to shoot in the
sooner state 240 million dollars has
been pumped into the state's economy in
the last year and a half
municipalities are also dangling dollars
places like Oklahoma City have started
offering rebates to film in town
shows and films like Matt Damon
Stillwater still owns Tulsa King and
DiCaprio's killers of the flower Moon
all benefited from these incentives
Oklahoma's Native American tribes like
the Chickasaw and Choctaw Nations have
all shot movies in the state
it takes a lot of people to stitch
together a movie in the last year and a
half Oklahoma's film industry created 10
000 jobs
costume designer Valerie Parker went
from working on prom dresses and theater
outfits to creating wardrobes for more
than 20 movie productions shot in the
state I just started getting more and
more recommendations so one led to
another to another to another where I
was on a production nearly every month a
real-life Film Studio is now at the
Heart of the City new businesses are
also taking Center Stage like the
tenants at what used to be Oklahoma
City's Convention Center cinelease one
of the largest equipment rental
companies in Hollywood recently set up
shop in OKC this Arena hosted big names
like Elvis Presley Tina Turner and Garth
Brooks now it's part of a 1.3 million
square feet Studio that hosts big
Hollywood Productions that's what
friends are for after more than 25 years
working as an actor in Hollywood so this
stage is 25 000 square feet Rachel
Cannon paired up with filmmaker and
writer Matt Payne to open Prairie surf
Studios
a One-Stop shop for the motion picture
industry with five sound stages
electrical grids and on-site audio
recording I think that we are growing
our crew base rapidly and I think we are
growing it in a way that we're really
putting qualified people to work
Oklahoma is still known for oil and gas
but Hollywood has arrived on the Prairie
there for CBS mornings Omar villafranca
Oklahoma City
wait go Rachel Rachel Cannon creating a
whole new business for herself I like
that and I like the Roman Valerie Parker
who went from making prom dresses to now
she's a bona fide customer for movies
very nice Oklahoma business is booming
yeah as we like to say not an oil boom
anymore Hollywood on the Prairie that's
a good nickname it is yeah bring people
in